is no move from the government to solve
these public sector pay disputes there's
certainly nothing
that we can recognize for the railway
and it seems to be a budget for the rich
and there'll be a continuous transfer of
wealth from working people because the
tax thresholds for ordinary workers have
not gone up but for the wealthy they can
put up to sixty thousand pounds a year
into their pension scheme and they will
have unlimited tax break on their
lifetime Journey so it seems A peculiar
pension A peculiar step to take where
you're giving more money to the wealthy
and taking money off the poor and that's
a transfer of wealth in our society
which we saw under list trust and
quasi-quarting and Jeremy Hunt's going
the same way it seems